This house on Washington Street in New York doesn't look like a house. It's more like an industrial building. Comes right up to the sidewalk-- red brick, steel window frames, and a grid of windows. It'd be considered a big house anywhere, but in New York, where people live in pretty small quarters--
纽约华盛顿街上的这栋房子看起来不像房子，更像是一座工业建筑。它紧邻人行道——红砖墙，钢制窗框，还有一排排整齐的窗户。无论在哪儿，这都会被认为是一栋大房子，但在纽约，人们居住的空间通常非常狭小——
I mean, it's huge. My building, I think, has 14 apartments. And I think this looks twice as big as it. And it's just him and his family. I don't know.
我是说，它太大了。我想我住的那栋楼里有14户人家，而这栋房子看起来比那大两倍。但这儿只住着他和他的家人。我不知道该说什么。
The "him" in this case is Noam Gottesman, a billionaire finance guy and art collector. The guy telling me about him is a neighbor from around the corner, Eyal Levin, not a billionaire, father of two teenage boys who share a bedroom. He runs a jewelry business with his wife. There's one other important feature on this immense house that he wants me to see-- bright yellow letters, neat and tidy and dignified, on the bank of windows. Eyal reads--
这个“他”指的是诺姆·戈特斯曼（Noam Gottesman），一位亿万富翁金融家兼艺术收藏家。向我介绍他的人是街角的一位邻居，艾亚尔·列文（Eyal Levin），他并非亿万富翁，而是两个十几岁儿子的父亲，兄弟俩共用一个卧室。他与妻子共同经营着一家珠宝店。他想让我看这栋巨大房子上的另一个重要特征——银行窗户上一排明黄色的字母，整洁、庄重。艾亚尔读道——
"No parking, active driveway." But when you live here, everybody knows he's bluffing.
“禁止停车，车辆进出口。”但当你住在这里时，每个人都知道他在虚张声势。
It's not a no parking zone, he says, because there's no driveway. There's no garage. There's just a big door. But by pretending to have a driveway, what this man gets, he says, is the kind of real estate money cannot buy in New York-- his own free parking space, right in front of his house. And parking-- parking is just beyond difficult in certain neighborhoods in New York. People cry over parking. It's so frustrating. And finding a space in this neighborhood, Eyal says--
他说，那不是禁停区，因为这里根本没有车道，也没有车库，只有一个大门。但通过假装有车道，他获得了一种在纽约花钱也买不到的房地产资源——他家门前那一块专属的免费停车位。在纽约的某些社区，停车简直是难如登天。人们会因为停车位而崩溃。这太令人沮丧了。艾亚尔说，在这个街区找个车位——
You sometimes go, make the rounds and rounds and rounds. And time passes. Sometimes it can take an hour, sometimes more.
你有时得在那儿转啊转，转个不停。时间就这样流逝。有时可能需要一个小时，甚至更久。
Eyal says that when he first noticed Gottesman's signs telling people not to park there, he respected the moxie.
艾亚尔说，当他第一次注意到戈特斯曼贴出的那些不准人们停车的牌子时，他挺佩服这家伙的胆量。
Initially, it was very funny. I actually chuckled. And I was like, wow, this guy, good for him for confiscating the parking. I mean, whenever I passed it, it was kind of funny. Like, look what this guy did.
起初，这挺有趣的。我当时真的笑了，心想，哇，这家伙，能霸占停车位，真有他的。每次经过那儿，我都觉得好笑，就像在看他到底做了什么一样。
But then one day, Eyal was driving around, looking for parking himself. It's taking forever. And he sees the space in front of Gottesman's house. And he decides, OK, this will be the day he'll park there.
但有一天，艾亚尔自己在开车找车位，找了半天也没找到。这时他看到了戈特斯曼家门前的空位。他决定，好吧，今天就要停在那儿。
Five, 10 seconds after, there's a security guard or two of them that barge out of the property. They have cameras all over so they see when you park, and they run out.
五到十秒钟后，一名或两名保安就从屋里冲了出来。他们在各处都装了摄像头，所以当你停车时他们能看到，然后就会跑出来。
He says they told him you can't park here. And they pointed to the signs on the door.
他说，他们告诉他这里不能停车，还指了指门上的牌子。
I was laughing. And I said, "Listen, guys, I'm a neighbor. I know what you're doing here. I personally don't care, but I'm allowed to park here." And then they start making threats. You will get out. Why are you being so difficult?
我当时在笑，我说：“听着，伙计们，我是邻居。我知道你们在搞什么名堂。我个人不在乎，但我有权停在这里。”然后他们就开始威胁我。说你会开走的。问我为什么要这么固执？
Eyal describes himself as somebody who's generally pretty mellow. And the first time he tried to park there, he decided it wasn't worth arguing about and pulled out. But the next time he needed a place to park, he poured into the space again. Again, the tough guys showed up. And this time, Eyal had had enough. He stood his ground.
艾亚尔形容自己通常是个随和的人。第一次尝试停车时，他觉得没必要争执，就开走了。但下次他需要车位时，又停了进去。那些凶悍的家伙又出现了。这次艾亚尔受够了，他坚决不走。
I was like, why am I being bullied when I know for a fact that I'm allowed to park there and that the signs are basically fakes?
我想，我明明有权停在那儿，那些牌子也基本是假的，我为什么要受这种欺负？
So he left his car there. He parked. Did it maybe a half dozen times, he says. Then one day, he's taking his son to school, walks by the parking space, and realizes his car is gone. They had him towed. Eyal believes the guards must have found a cop who'd write a ticket and then called for the tow truck. The ticket later got thrown out. But to get his car back, Eyal still had the hassle of riding the subway out to the tow lot. It was in a part of Queens called Maspeth. It was a subway ride and a 20-minute walk, he says. He also had to pay $201 to get the car back.
于是他把车留在那里。他说，他大概停了六次。直到有一天，他送儿子上学，经过那个停车位时，发现车不见了。他们把他的车拖走了。艾亚尔认为保安一定是找了个警察开了罚单，然后叫了拖车。那张罚单后来被撤销了，但为了拿回车，艾亚尔还是不得不费劲坐地铁去位于皇后区马斯佩斯（Maspeth）的拖车场。他说那是一趟地铁车程外加二十分钟的步行。他还付了201美元才把车取回来。
I mean, at the time, I was enraged. It's ludicrous. It's my car. It's public space. I don't care how much money you have. I'm still allowed to park on the street.
说实话，当时我气疯了。这太荒谬了。那是我的车，这是公共空间。我不管你有多少钱，我依然有权在街上停车。
So the neighbor had cameras, guards, money, and, Eyal thought, cops they could talk into writing tickets for something that is not illegal. But Eyal had some moves, too. Sent the story to the tabloids, talked to reporters.
所以，这位邻居有摄像头、保安、钱，艾亚尔还认为，他们甚至能说动警察为本不违法的行为开罚单。但艾亚尔也有自己的应对办法。他把故事发给了小报，联系了记者。
Then I wake up in the morning, and I see it online. And I'm like, whoa. It was the whole front page.
结果第二天早上上网一看，天哪，我的故事上了头版。
And what was the headline again?
当时的头条标题是什么来着？
Uh--
呃——
We're in his apartment for this part of the conversation. And he heads over to a cardboard box behind his couch, next to a bin of soccer and basketballs, rustles through some stuff, and pulls out three different days of the New York Daily News where this story is the front page. You can't buy that kind of real estate in New York either. The front pages of the New York tabloids are like the Madison Square Garden of journalism, usually reserved for the top acts-- cheating celebrities, no-goodnik mayors, headless bodies in topless bars, A-Rod.
我们在这段对话时就在他的公寓里。他走向沙发后一个纸箱，旁边是一筐足球和篮球，翻找了一番，拿出了三份刊登这则故事的《纽约每日新闻》头版。这种房地产你也是买不到的。纽约小报的头版就像是新闻界的麦迪逊广场花园，通常只留给顶级新闻——出轨的名人、坏市长、裸体酒吧里的无头尸体，或者棒球明星A-Rod。
So all over the first page, they've got a great headline, I think-- "Tow-tal Jerk."
所以头版上全是关于这事的，标题很棒，我觉得——“拖走混蛋”（Tow-tal Jerk）。
And they spelled total, T-O-W, dash, T-A-L.
他们把Total拼成了T-O-W-dash-T-A-L。
Right.
对。
Get it? Tow, like they towed his car. He's interviewed for radio and TV. There are follow-up stories. The mayor's office declares that hogging a parking space like this is shameful. The Department of Buildings sends out an inspector. And the billionaire Gottesman is eventually told that if he wants to call this a driveway, he needs to install a proper garage door. Eyal gets why the story had such legs. It's got something for everybody.
明白吗？Tow（拖走），就像他们拖走了他的车。他接受了广播和电视采访。后续还有报道。市长办公室宣布这种霸占车位的行为是可耻的。建筑局派去了检查员。最终，亿万富翁戈特斯曼被告知，如果他想把那里称为车道，就得安装一个正式的车库门。艾亚尔明白为什么这个故事能引起这么大的反响。它满足了所有人的期待。
A rich guy, a mansion, a car being towed, how the rich always get away with it.
富人、豪宅、车被拖走，还有那种富人总能逃脱惩罚的共识。
It's David versus Goliath.
这是大卫对战歌利亚。
Yeah. And I'm David. Nice to meet you.
是的，我是大卫。很高兴见到你。
For the next few days, wherever I walk, I get stopped by neighbors.
接下来的几天里，无论我走到哪儿，都有邻居把我拦下来。
He learns that other people in the neighborhood have noticed the billionaire and his parking space. He becomes a magnet for their stories about run-ins with the neighbor's security guards. In Eyal's building, when they had their annual meeting, there were people he's known for 10 years.
他了解到社区里其他人也注意到了那个亿万富翁和他的车位。他成了邻居们讲述与那家保安发生冲突故事的磁石。在艾亚尔的楼里开年度会议时，遇见了认识十年的邻居。
And I got applause there. They were like, how did you do it? And one older neighbor was like, I've been trying to fight them for years because I was so upset about it. He doesn't even have a car, but just whenever he passes it, he was getting upset about it.
大家都为我鼓掌。他们问我是怎么做到的？还有一位老邻居说，他多年来一直试图反抗他们，因为这让他非常心烦。他甚至没有车，但每次经过那儿，他都会感到生气。
After talking to Eyal, I reached out to Noam Gotteman's spokesperson. Noam Gottesman agreed to talk to me, though he didn't want me to record. When we got on the phone, he told me he totally understood why people got so upset at Eyal's story. But he said Eyal is wrong about the most basic fact in the story. Eyal thinks it's legal to park in that space. And he thinks he only got a ticket because he was targeted by Noam's security guards.
在采访艾亚尔后，我联系了诺姆·戈特斯曼的发言人。诺姆·戈特斯曼同意与我交谈，但他不希望我录音。在电话里，他告诉我，他完全理解为什么大家对艾亚尔的故事感到那么愤怒。但他表示，艾亚尔在故事最基本的事实上搞错了。艾亚尔认为那个位置是合法停车位，并认为他被开罚单是因为被诺姆的保安针对了。
Noam Gottesman said that nobody can park there. That when he built his house, the curb was already cut low for a driveway-- had been that way for decades, and he left it that way. And the Department of Buildings approved it as a loading bay and driveway. And he says they do load and unload stuff into his house through a massive door there. Like I said, he's a big art collector. Because it is approved by the city for this purpose, Noam said, it is not legal to park there, same as other driveways and loading bays in the neighborhood.
诺姆·戈特斯曼说，没人能停在那儿。他盖房子时，路缘石就已经为了车道而做成了低位，几十年都是这样，他只是保留了原样。建筑局也批准那里作为装卸区和车道。他说，他们的确通过那里的一扇大门搬运物品。就像我说的，他是位大艺术收藏家。他说，因为那里被城市批准用于此用途，所以在那儿停车是非法的，就像社区里的其他车道和装卸区一样。
He says other cars have gotten tickets there. And in fact, he doesn't park there in front of his own home because he's gotten a ticket there. It was so many years ago. Unlike Eyal, he didn't have a copy he could show me. He says he pays to park in the garage, or he finds a parking space and then walks home like all the non-billionaires in the neighborhood do. I'm paraphrasing here. He didn't actually call anybody a non-billionaire in our conversation.
他说其他车在那儿也吃过罚单。事实上，他自己也不把车停在自家门口，因为他以前也吃过罚单，不过那是多年前的事了。和艾亚尔不同，他拿不出当年的罚单副本给我看。他说他会花钱把车停进车库，或者像社区里所有非亿万富翁一样，找个停车位后步行回家。我这是在转述，他在对话中并没有称呼任何人是非亿万富翁。
But checking into it, I learned he's right. The space in front of Noam's house was, in fact, not a legal parking space. Eyal's ticket was legit. I will note tickets seemed very rare for that spot. The police told us they haven't issued one this whole year. And Noam says he's never heard of anybody else being towed from that spot besides Eyal.
但在调查后，我发现他是对的。诺姆家门前的空间确实不是合法的停车位。艾亚尔的罚单是合法的。我注意到在那儿开罚单的情况似乎非常罕见。警方告诉我们，今年他们还没在那儿开过罚单。诺姆也说，他从没听说除了艾亚尔之外还有人被从那儿拖过车。
So if I had to guess, I would guess that after a half dozen arguments with Eyal, Noam's security guards were fed up with him and called over a friendly cop to write a ticket and called the towing company. When I suggested this to Noam, he categorically denied it. Said he did not arrange for that to happen, that he asked his security guards. They said they didn't do it either.
所以如果让我猜，我会猜在和艾亚尔争吵六次后，诺姆的保安对他忍无可忍，于是找了个相熟的警察开了罚单，并叫来了拖车公司。当我向诺姆提出这一点时，他坚决否认。他说他没有安排这种事，还问了他的保安，他们也说没做过。
Though the towing company did tell the Daily News that someone phoned from Noam's house to ask for Eyal's car to be towed. When I later asked Noam's spokesperson why they would say that, it is not true, she said she had no idea.
不过，拖车公司确实告诉《每日新闻》，有人从诺姆家打来电话要求拖走艾亚尔的车。后来我问诺姆的发言人为什么他们会这么说（如果不是真的），她说她也不知道。
Eyal, meanwhile, doesn't buy it. He says there's no way he would have been towed without Noam's guards making it happen. Says the city shouldn't have approved this as a driveway in the first place because it's not really a driveway in any normal sense of the word. But even though he thinks he's in the right--
与此同时，艾亚尔并不买账。他说，如果没有诺姆的保安插手，他的车绝不可能被拖走。他还说，城市根本不应该批准这里作为车道，因为它在任何常理定义下都不算车道。但尽管他认为自己占理——
I didn't park again in that spot since it happened. I'm sometimes tempted when I-- and then I'm like, I don't want to go to Maspeth again. And this is where the bullying sometimes works.
自从那次以后，我就没再停在那儿了。有时我也会想——但随后我就对自己说，我不想再跑一趟马斯佩斯了。这就是欺凌有时候有效的原因。
Today, on our show, one man's bullying is another man's simple adherence to New York parking law. It's hard being neighbors when things get angry or ugly or seem unfair. It's like everybody is just stuck with each other. You know, it's hard to move away. Moving away is for quitters.
今天，在我们的节目中，一个人的欺凌是另一个人对纽约停车法规的简单遵守。当事情变得愤怒、丑陋或看起来不公平时，做邻居很难。就像每个人都被困在了一起。你知道，搬走很难。搬走的人是懦夫。
Today, we have a story of a very different group of neighbors in a very different place. And a man moves in who breaks all kinds of rules, and the neighbors have to figure out what to do about it. And nobody backs down. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
今天，我们讲一个关于一群非常不同的邻居在一个非常不同的地方的故事。一个打破所有规则的人搬了进来，邻居们不得不决定该怎么办。没人退缩。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, "Home, Home Near the Range." So what you're about to hear takes place not in a city, but in a small town in Vermont-- Pawlet, Vermont. Think rolling green hills, red barns. And pretty peaceful, until a stranger comes to town, buys up some land.
第一幕，“家，家，在那牧场附近”。你接下来要听到的故事不是发生在城市里，而是发生在佛蒙特州的一个小镇——帕莱特（Pawlet）。想象一下连绵起伏的青山、红色谷仓。这里原本很平静，直到一个陌生人搬进城里，买下了一些土地。
The neighbors aren't exactly sure what to make of this guy. And then problems start. And things escalate in a pretty serious and intense way, probably because this new guy, not only does he not play by the rules, in fact, he seems to feed off breaking them. This story's going to be the rest of our show today. Reporter Mike Giglio tells what happened.
邻居们并不确定该如何看待这个家伙，接着问题就开始了。事情以一种非常严重且紧张的方式升级，可能是因为这个新人不仅不按规矩办事，而且似乎以打破规则为乐。这个故事将占据我们今天节目的剩余部分。记者迈克·吉格里奥（Mike Giglio）讲述了发生的一切。
It all started with a gate. A man named Daniel Banyai bought a wooded 30-acre property between some farmland and a slate quarry back in 2013. The neighbors didn't see much of him for a while. They noticed construction vehicles rumbling up and down the road. And they figured he was building a house. Mandy Hulett and her husband, Rich, owned a farm next to Daniel's property. Here's Mandy.
这一切始于一个大门。2013年，一个名叫丹尼尔·巴尼亚（Daniel Banyai）的男人在农田和石板矿场之间买下了一处30英亩的林地。邻居们有一阵子没怎么见到他。他们注意到施工车辆在路上轰隆隆地开进开出，以为他在盖房子。曼迪·休利特（Mandy Hulett）和她的丈夫里奇（Rich）在丹尼尔的地盘旁边拥有一家农场。这是曼迪。
A good friend of ours used to own that property. And he sold the property to him. And the very first time we met him, he came down to the farm. And he was actually-- he was OK. But the next thing we knew-- it was like two weeks later-- he was erecting a gate on our property.
我们的一位好朋友曾拥有那块地。他把它卖给了他。我们第一次见到他时，他来到农场，他其实表现得还行。但接下来我们就知道了——那是两周后——他在我们的土地上竖起了一扇门。
Daniel's land is actually surrounded by other people's property. It's kind of like an island. So in order to access it, he has the right to cross the Huletts' land. There's a long driveway. Daniel put a gate at his end of it, but his gate was on the Huletts' property. Mandy and Rich are in their 40s. They have two kids. They own a lot of farmland and a trucking company. Rich grew up there. His family's been in the area since before the Civil War.
丹尼尔的土地实际上被别人的土地包围着，像个孤岛。所以为了进入，他有权穿过休利特一家的土地。那儿有一条长长的车道。丹尼尔在他的那一端设了一扇门，但他那扇门设在了休利特一家的土地上。曼迪和里奇四十多岁，有两个孩子。他们拥有很多农田和一家货运公司。里奇从小在那儿长大。他的家族从南北战争前就住在这个地区了。
So Rich approached him and said, "You do know that you put your gate-- I don't know-- 10 feet onto our property." And he's like, "I'll put my gate wherever I want to put my gate." And Rich said, "Well, in Vermont, we put our gate on our own property or on the property line, not on somebody else's property."
所以里奇走过去对他讲：“你知道你把门装在哪儿了吗？大概在我们的土地上伸进来了10英尺。”他回答说：“我想把门装哪儿就装哪儿。”里奇说：“好吧，在佛蒙特州，我们把门装在自己的土地上或者边界线上，而不是别人的土地上。”
And I think he gave him two or three weeks to remove it. And if you don't, I'm going to come remove it. And he's like, "You're never going to get that out of the ground." So he gave him two or three weeks. And he didn't move it. So Rich went up with a payloader and brought a witness with him as well and just picked it up off out of the ground and tossed it onto his property, back on his own property. [LAUGHS]
我想他给了他两三周的时间把它拆掉。如果你不拆，我就亲自去拆。他说：“你永远别想把它从土里弄出来。”所以里奇给了他两三周时间。他没动。于是里奇开着装载机，还带了个见证人，直接把它从地里拔出来，扔到了他的土地上，回到他自己的地盘了。[笑声]
So things were off to a bad start. Daniel was a newcomer to the area. He was from upstate New York, but other than that, he was guarded about his background. He told one neighbor he'd been in the Army. Then there was a rumor around town that he'd been a Navy SEAL or federal agent or something. It wasn't clear.
所以事情从一开始就很糟糕。丹尼尔是这个地区的新人。他来自纽约州北部，除此之外，他对自己的背景守口如瓶。他告诉一个邻居他在军队待过。镇上接着传言说他是海军海豹突击队员或者联邦特工什么的。并不明确。
And just a word about the place he'd moved to-- this part of Pawlet, it's a bit isolated, up on a hill. There are about a dozen households all spread out along a couple of roads. There are the Huletts, John Davis, a Vietnam vet, and his wife, Val. Then down the hill was Beth Duquette, a former librarian, and her husband, Ray. Paul and Michelle Tilander are grandparents who moved to the area about 10 years ago. People are pretty private here, but they help each other out. This is Ray and Michelle, who lives one house down from him.
关于他搬去的地方再说两句——帕莱特的这一部分比较偏僻，在山上。那里散落着十几户人家，沿几条路分布。有休利特一家、越战老兵约翰·戴维斯（John Davis）和他的妻子瓦尔（Val）。山下住着前图书管理员贝丝·杜凯特（Beth Duquette）和她的丈夫雷（Ray）。保罗（Paul）和米歇尔·蒂兰德（Michelle Tilander）是一对祖父母，大约10年前搬到了这里。大家都很注重隐私，但会互相帮忙。这是雷和米歇尔，她住在离他家一户的地方。
Paul and Michelle moved in next door to me.
保罗和米歇尔搬到了我的隔壁。
I love this story.
我喜欢这个故事。
I told them.
我告诉过他们。
I know what he's going to say.
我知道他要说什么。
If you ever have an emergency, call me first, then call 911, because the cops won't show up, but I will.
如果你遇到紧急情况，先打给我，再打911，因为警察不会来，但我会来。
And that's the way we roll around here.
这就是我们这儿的规矩。
Most of them came here for the landscape and the quiet. And then, one day, the woods erupted with gunfire, hundreds and hundreds of rounds. This is Beth Moser-Duquette, the former librarian.
他们大多数人来到这里是为了风景和宁静。然后有一天，树林里传来了枪声，成百上千发。这是贝丝·莫泽-杜凯特，那位前图书管理员。
I mean, it was just shooting on a daily basis, like di-di-di-di-di. Di-di-di-di-di.
我的意思是，那是每天都在射击，砰砰砰砰砰。砰砰砰砰砰。
I want to point out, Pawlet is not a gun-shy town. Beth told me that gunfire is the sound of Vermont. She's a longtime NRA member. The area's mixed politically. Some of the neighbors voted for Trump. Others went for Biden. But none of them has a problem with firearms. Farmers have their varmint guns, and hunters have their rifles. And no one bats an eye at a neighbor doing some practice with an AR-15. This was different.
我想指出，帕莱特不是一个怕枪的小镇。贝丝告诉我，枪声就是佛蒙特州的声音。她是美国步枪协会（NRA）的资深会员。这个地区政治立场复杂。一些邻居投票给特朗普，其他人支持拜登，但他们都没人对枪支有意见。农民有防害兽用的枪，猎人有他们的步枪。没人会对邻居练习使用AR-15感到惊讶。但这不一样。
We didn't know what was going on. We were like, what, it sounds like Vietnam.
我们不知道发生了什么。我们当时想，这听起来像越南战场。
This is Michelle Tilander, the grandmother who lives with her husband, Paul.
这是米歇尔·蒂兰德，和丈夫保罗住在一起的祖母。
Here in Vermont, you expect to hear somebody out there, plunking away at their targets, getting ready for turkey season or hunting season or just keeping their firearms in tune. We do that. That's expected, but not what we heard. That was totally out of the zone.
在佛蒙特州，你会预料到听到有人在外面，砰砰砰地打靶子，为火鸡季或狩猎季做准备，或者只是为了让枪支保持良好的状态。我们也这样做。那是在意料之中的，但我们听到的不是这样。这完全超出了常态。
Did you try to approach him at that point?
那时候你们试着接近他了吗？
No, at that point, I was too afraid to approach anybody that was firing that much weaponry because that's not normal, certainly for this area. I don't think I would want to approach anybody that was firing off 1,000 rounds. That's scary.
没有，那时候我太害怕去接近任何正在发射那么多武器的人了，因为那不正常，肯定不是这个区域的常态。我想我不会想去接近任何正在发射1000发子弹的人。那太可怕了。
Daniel had opened up a gun range. John Davis, the Vietnam vet, was tipped off about it by a friend. John got in his truck and drove up and down the hill, knocking on doors to alert everyone. He told me it was like Paul Revere's ride. Mandy Hulett and another neighbor walked the property line around Daniel's place. They peered through the trees and saw some silhouette targets in dirt berms. Mandy worried that someone would end up shooting towards the road.
丹尼尔开了一个射击场。越战老兵约翰·戴维斯被朋友告知了这件事。约翰跳上他的卡车，在山上开来开去，敲开邻居们的门警示大家。他告诉我说，那就像保罗·里维尔的骑行预警。曼迪·休利特和其他邻居沿着丹尼尔家的地界走了一圈。他们透过树木窥视，看到了一些泥土护堤上的轮廓靶。曼迪担心会有人向马路方向射击。
And the trajectory of those bullets is actually right to my brother-in-law's house and then right to the school, right over the hill.
而那些子弹的弹道正好对着我姐夫家，然后穿过山丘直冲学校。
The neighbors did not want a shooting range in their backyard. Daniel had filed for a permit not to open a shooting range, but for what he called a school, apparently where he would do classroom firearms instruction. In order to build the school on his property, Daniel needed permission to widen his driveway through the neighbor's land. So he asked the Huletts if they would give him the extra space. The Huletts said no. His neighbors on the other side said no as well.
邻居们不想在自家后院有个射击场。丹尼尔申请的许可证不是为了开射击场，而是他所谓的“学校”，显然是在那儿进行课堂枪支教学。为了在土地上盖学校，丹尼尔需要许可来拓宽穿过邻居土地的车道。所以他问休利特一家愿不愿意给他多一点空间。休利特一家拒绝了。另一边的邻居也拒绝了。
Daniel's permit application for a school was denied, but he'd already put up the building, and he just kept going. He also didn't have the right permit to operate a shooting range on his land. But of course, he was doing that, too. What he was developing was a sprawling facility, the kind that military contractors or law enforcement or self-styled militia might use. He called it Slate Ridge. I reached out to Daniel. He didn't want to be interviewed. But he lays the whole thing out in this YouTube video.
丹尼尔的学校许可证申请被拒了，但他已经盖好了建筑，而且一直在继续开。他也没有合适的许可证在土地上运营射击场，但当然，他也在那样做。他正在开发的是一个庞大的设施，那种军事承包商、执法机构或自称民兵组织可能会使用的设施。他称其为“石板岭”（Slate Ridge）。我联系了丹尼尔，他不想接受采访。但他在这个YouTube视频里把一切都展示了出来。
Slate Ridge is 100% predicated on the practitioner model. Gunfighters, professionals that use the firearm as a tool in the line of their employment.
石板岭100%基于从业者模式。枪手，以枪支为工作工具的专业人员。
Daniel is six feet tall and stout, with a bushy beard. That's how he talks-- lots of jargon. The video is shot by a dude named Adam McLain, who associates himself with the Boogaloo Bois, an armed movement that calls for civil war. His Twitter handle is boojahideen.
丹尼尔身高六英尺，身材魁梧，留着浓密的胡须。他说话就是这样——充满了行话。视频是一个名叫亚当·麦克莱恩（Adam McLain）的家伙拍摄的，他把自己与“布加洛男孩”（Boogaloo Bois）联系在一起，这是一个呼吁内战的武装运动。他的推特账号是boojahideen。
So this is Range One. This is what started Slate Ridge, right? I built this first. And I continued to proceed on my dream.
所以这是第一个靶场。这就是石板岭的起源，对吧？我先建了这个。然后我继续追求我的梦想。
He shows Adam the school and a surprisingly fancy bunkhouse and two shooting ranges, one with a wraparound berm that's intended to let people fire in multiple directions to more closely mirror real-life combat. There's a spot where people can practice entering and clearing a building and a place where they can detonate explosives. After the tour, Daniel and Adam sit down for an interview.
他向亚当展示了学校、一个令人惊讶的豪华宿舍和两个射击场，其中一个带有环绕式护堤，旨在让人们能向多个方向射击，以更贴近现实战斗。有一个地方供人们练习进入并清理建筑物，还有一个地方可以引爆炸药。参观结束后，丹尼尔和亚当坐下来进行了一次采访。
So you're a private contractor. How long were you a private contractor for?
所以你是一名私人承包商。你做了多久的私人承包商？
For several years.
有好几年了。
For several years?
有好几年了？
Several years, yes.
好几年，是的。
OK.
好的。
In the video, Daniel is wearing green military style cargo pants and green wraparound shades. He tells Adam the origin story of Slate Ridge. He says the idea came to him on his first overseas deployment as a private military contractor.
在视频中，丹尼尔穿着绿色军用风格的工装裤和绿色环绕式墨镜。他告诉亚当石板岭的起源故事。他说这个想法是在他第一次作为私人军事承包商海外部署时产生的。
I remember that day like it was just yesterday. I bumped up with about 12 guys that I had no idea who they were. I didn't know much about them. I tried out with these guys. I made it on the team. And then we get there, right? We're out of the United States of America. And we're in it.
我还记得那一天，就像昨天一样。我遇到了大约12个人，我根本不知道他们是谁。我对他们了解不多。我和这些家伙一起参加选拔。我加入了团队。然后我们到达那里，对吧？我们离开了美利坚合众国。我们就在那儿。
And that night, when we hit our bunks, I watched-- with all due respect, because some of those guys I have become very good friends with. Some of those guys are my battle buddies now, and some of those guys, I would bleed for them. But a lot of them turned into a totally different person. Here, we had men crying, shivering, and second guessing themselves. And I sat there, and I watched these men. And I said, wow, what did I get myself into?
那天晚上，当我们躺在铺位上时，我看着——恕我直言，因为其中一些人后来成了我的好朋友。他们现在是我的战斗伙伴，有些人我愿意为他们流血。但其中许多人变成了一个完全不同的人。在这里，我们有男人在哭泣、颤抖，质疑自己。我坐在那儿，看着这些男人。我说，哇，我到底卷进了什么？
The problem was they weren't properly trained. So he decided to start his own training facility. He tells Adam he put $1.6 million of his own money into building the place. To Daniel, Slate Ridge is more than a shooting range. It's a place for people who define themselves by owning guns. He refers to himself as a professional gunfighter.
问题是他们没有接受过适当的训练。所以他决定创办自己的培训设施。他告诉亚当，他投入了160万美元的个人资金来建设这个地方。对丹尼尔来说，石板岭不仅仅是一个射击场。它是为那些通过拥有枪支来定义自己的人准备的地方。他自称是一名专业枪手。
In the military, we had the three M's-- the mission, the men, then me. I'm always at the last.
在军队里，我们有三个M原则——任务（Mission）、男人（Men），然后是我（Me）。我总是排在最后。
"I'm an Army guy," he tells Adam. Daniel talks about his service a lot. At one town meeting, where he made his case for the school building, he described himself as a veteran who's passionate about guns. He paints his work as a private contractor in patriotic terms. In court, he tells a state judge--
“我是个军人，”他告诉亚当。丹尼尔经常谈论他的服役经历。在一次镇民会议上，他为学校建筑辩护时，形容自己是一位对枪支充满热情的退伍军人。他用爱国主义的辞藻来描述他的私人承包商工作。在法庭上，他告诉一位州法官——
OK, Your Honor, last thing I'd like to add is that, within 30 days, I will be out of the country--
好的，法官大人，我想补充的最后一件事是，30天内，我就会出国——
OK.
好的。
--so.
——所以。
Let me ask you this. How long are you gone for?
让我问你这个。你要走多久？
I'm not sure. I'm waiting for the deployment orders to come in. It may be a few months.
我不确定。我正在等待部署命令下达。可能是几个月。
OK, all right. Well, please be safe in those travels, OK? And thank you for your service, sir.
好的，好吧。嗯，祝你在旅途中平安，好吗？谢谢你的服役，先生。
The neighbors wondered if even the most basic part of his biography, that he'd been in the military, was a lie. John Davis, the Vietnam vet, wasn't sure he bought it.
邻居们怀疑他简历中最基本的部分——他曾在军队服役——是否是一个谎言。越战老兵约翰·戴维斯不确定他是否相信这一点。
If you're a veteran, there's nothing more disreputable than somebody claims to be something he isn't. And I have no use for people that go around and act like they're something they aren't.
如果你是一名退伍军人，没有什么比有人自称是某种他不是的人更丢脸的了。我对那些到处装腔作势的人毫无好感。
After Slate Ridge opened at the end of 2017, its Facebook page racked up a few thousand followers. Daniel started referring to them as "the Slate Ridge family." He hosted classes on shooting and tactical training and field first aid. The neighbors would see strangers driving up and down their shared dirt road. Sometimes the shooting would go on all weekend.
2017年底石板岭开放后，它的脸书主页积累了几千名粉丝。丹尼尔开始称他们为“石板岭大家庭”。他主持关于射击、战术训练和战地急救的课程。邻居们会看到陌生人在他们共用的土路上开来开去。有时射击会持续整个周末。
The neighbors hadn't been all that close before this started, just friendly in that small town kind of way. But the conflict with Daniel brought them together. They started meeting in John Davis's workshop. Sometimes a couple dozen people would show up. Their weapon of choice was as American as the Winchester rifle-- zoning laws, those most basic rules for how neighbors are going to live next to one another.
在这之前，邻居们并没有那么亲近，只是那种小镇式的友好。但与丹尼尔的冲突把他们聚在了一起。他们开始在约翰·戴维斯的作坊里开会。有时会有二十多个人出现。他们选择的武器和温彻斯特步枪一样地道——分区法，那是邻居们如何和睦相处的底线规则。
This area was zoned residential and agricultural. Daniel went back to the town and argued for a variance in the zoning laws so he could finally get a permit for the school building. 46 people signed a petition opposing this. They showed up at the town meeting in force. Here's Michelle.
这个区域被划分为住宅区和农业区。丹尼尔回到镇上，要求更改分区法，这样他最终能为学校建筑获得许可证。46人签署了反对请愿书。他们集体出席了镇会议。这是米歇尔。
I thought maybe the town would step in, and we'd go to a couple select board meetings. We thought for sure it would be brought under control, I'd say within six months.
我以为镇政府会介入，我们会去参加几次选择委员会会议。我们确信，不出六个月，这事就会得到控制。
There's no recording of the meeting where Daniel asked for the zoning variance, but there's official minutes. This kind of captures the feeling of it. Quote, "Gary Hadeka addressed the board as an abutting landowner and interested party. Mr. Hadeka explained that as an owner of a horse stable, they have a lot to lose, that they do not want to live through a war, and that they were there first. He expressed that he wishes to stay on their property and is entitled to peace and quiet."
丹尼尔要求更改分区的那次会议没有录音，但有官方会议记录。这捕捉到了当时的感觉。引述：“加里·哈德卡（Gary Hadeka）作为毗邻土地所有者和相关方向委员会发表讲话。哈德卡先生解释说，作为马厩所有者，他们损失惨重，他们不想生活在战争中，而且他们先到这里。他表示他希望留在自己的土地上，享有和平与宁静。”
But the town zoning board decided in Daniel's favor. Said he was right. He could have his zoning variance for the school building. The neighbors appealed. For the next few years, he'd apply for permits. They'd try to stop him. Sometimes they won. Sometimes he won, and they'd appeal to the town or the state court. Eventually, the town of Pawlet took the neighbors' side and filed a case against Daniel, too, for violating its zoning laws.
但镇分区委员会做出了对丹尼尔有利的决定。说是他赢了。他可以获得学校建筑的分区变通许可。邻居们提起了上诉。接下来的几年里，他一直申请许可证。他们试图阻止他。有时他们赢了。有时他赢了，他们就向镇法院或州法院上诉。最终，帕莱特镇站在了邻居这一边，也对丹尼尔提起了诉讼，理由是他违反了分区法。
But this kind of thing can move really slowly. Beth, the former librarian, knew the state's environmental laws and looked for a way to use them against Daniel. She peered into his property from a neighbor's yard one day and noticed what looked like wetlands. Those are often protected in Vermont, which is no small thing because the state can crack down on people for even small seeming environmental problems, like manure.
但这类事情进展缓慢。前图书管理员贝丝了解州的环保法，寻找一种方法利用它们来对付丹尼尔。有一天，她从邻居院子里窥视他的土地，发现看起来像是湿地。在佛蒙特州，这通常是受到保护的，这可不是小事，因为州政府会对甚至看起来很小的环境问题严厉打击，比如粪便。
We're farmers, so we're allowed to spread manure. From April 15, we start to spread our manure, and December 15 is our cutoff. December 16 comes along, and you spread, Agency of Natural Resources would be so quick here, like on a fly on you-know-what. And we'd be fined.
我们是农民，所以我们被允许撒粪。从4月15日起，我们开始撒粪，12月15日是截止日期。12月16日到了，如果你还撒，自然资源署就会像盯上一团那个什么东西一样迅速地盯上你。我们就会被罚款。
Beth's an environmentalist. She was on a local conservation board at the time. She contacted the state's Department of Agriculture and the Natural Resources Board, trying to get someone to investigate. There was no quick response. Nobody stepped in to stop Daniel.
贝丝是一位环保主义者。她当时在当地的保护委员会任职。她联系了州农业部和自然资源委员会，试图找人调查。没有快速回应。没人介入去阻止丹尼尔。
And it was all falling upon deaf ears. Who do we go to? Who do we tell? Who do we talk to?
而且这全都落在了聋子的耳朵里。我们该找谁？我们该告诉谁？我们该和谁谈？
Daniel fought back, and not just in the town hall and the courts. In the winter of 2019, the neighbors got holiday cards with the Slate Ridge logo printed on them. Each one had a handwritten message. Here's Michelle Tilander, the grandmother, and John Davis, the Paul Revere guy.
丹尼尔进行了回击，而且不仅仅是在镇政府大厅和法庭上。2019年冬天，邻居们收到了印有石板岭标志的节日卡片。每张上都有手写的消息。这是祖母米歇尔·蒂兰德和“保罗·里维尔”约翰·戴维斯。
Yeah, all of us in the neighborhood got one. And some of them were pretty--
是的，我们社区里的所有人都收到了一张。其中一些相当——
Can I read mine?
我可以读读我的那张吗？
Yes, you can.
当然可以。
I got together with a group of these neighbors on Beth's front lawn. She set out a table with muffins and Dunkin' Donuts coffee.
我和这群邻居在贝丝的前草坪上聚在一起。她摆了一张桌子，上面有松饼和唐恩都乐咖啡。
Let me see. There's mine. Some of them were pretty filthy, so there's some I'm not going to read, but there you go, John.
让我看看。这是我的。其中一些非常下流，所以有些我不打算读，但给你，约翰。
Oh, yeah. This is Mr. and Mrs. Davis, and our address, a.k.a. Davis Trash. "From all of us at Slate Ridge, we wanted to wish you two miserable souls a wonderful holiday season. People hate you two inbreds. We are so fortunate you are our neighbors. Please feel free to move away, because no one likes alcoholics." Because we have a front porch, and in the summer, at the end of the day, we'll sit out there and have a beer. But I mean, this is just typical. They're all like this.
噢，是的。这是戴维斯夫妇，还有我们的地址，也就是“戴维斯垃圾”。“石板岭全体成员祝你们这两个可怜的灵魂节日快乐。人们讨厌你们这两个近亲通婚的。我们很幸运你们是我们的邻居。请随意搬走，因为没人喜欢酒鬼。”因为我们有前廊，夏天的时候，一天结束时，我们会在那儿坐着喝杯啤酒。但我的意思是，这就是典型的作风。他们都这样。
Especially after a big season.
尤其是在大旺季之后。
We're all inbreds. We're all--
我们都是近亲通婚的。我们都是——
Oh, this-- did you want me to read yours?
噢，这个——你想让我读你的吗？
Absolutely.
当然。
Oh, this is disgusting.
噢，这太恶心了。
The cards are in these binders. The neighbors brought them to the meeting, in this huge plastic bin, the kind you'd store your old clothes in. They're each labeled carefully with a label maker. There's "Pawlet Zoning Regulations" and "Slate Ridge Facebook Postings" and "Odds and Ends/Unfinished Business." This was the moment I realized how much the conflict with Daniel had taken over the neighbors' lives. There's maybe 20 of these binders. And inside are all the pieces of information that the neighbors have spent the last few years obsessively documenting about Daniel and Slate Ridge.
卡片被放在这些活页夹里。邻居们把它们带到了会议上，放在一个巨大的塑料箱里，就是那种你用来存旧衣服的箱子。它们都被用标签机仔细贴了标签。有“帕莱特分区条例”、“石板岭脸书贴文”和“零零碎碎/未竟之事”。这一刻，我意识到与丹尼尔的冲突占据了邻居们多少生活。大约有20个这样的活页夹。里面装的是邻居们过去几年里强迫性地记录下的关于丹尼尔和石板岭的所有信息。
Michelle, what does this say on the inside of this binder here?
米歇尔，这个活页夹里面写了什么？
Threats, postal cards, and then also some stalking problems here.
威胁、明信片，还有一些跟踪问题。
OK--
好的——
But all the threats. Everything, we try to keep it compiled.
所有的威胁。每一件事，我们都试图整理好。
I asked the neighbors where they keep the binders, and they wouldn't tell me. They'd only say it was a remote, locked facility. Here's Paul, describing a Facebook post they've got in one of the binders. It was on the Slate Ridge page.
我问邻居们把活页夹存放在哪儿，他们没告诉我。他们只说是一个遥远、锁好的地方。这是保罗，描述他们活页夹里的一篇脸书文章。它在石板岭主页上。
He put a picture of our house. And he captioned it, "Any day above ground is a good day. These people will be leaving soon."
他贴了一张我们房子的照片。标题写着：“地表之上的每一天都是好日子。这些人很快就会离开。”
How did you feel when that happened?
当时你感觉如何？
Unsafe.
不安全。
And this is John Davis again. John and his wife moved to Pawlet 43 years ago, in large part because his PTSD was so bad when he came back from Vietnam. He wanted the quiet.
这是约翰·戴维斯。约翰和他的妻子43年前搬到帕莱特，很大程度上是因为他从越南回来时PTSD太严重了。他想要宁静。
My wife and I were down and visiting my sister for about three days. And he posted on his website, the Davises are away. And then some of his disciples posted, "Oh, really? They're away." So we cut our visit short.
我和妻子出去探望我姐姐大约三天。他在他的网站上发帖说，戴维斯一家出远门了。然后他的一些信徒发帖说，“噢，真的吗？他们出远门了。”所以我们缩短了行程。
Last fall, the Slate Ridge Facebook account posted a photo of an SUV and said they were looking for one like it to use for something called vehicle assault class, where the vehicle will be shot and then blown up. The SUV in the post was the exact same make, model, and color as an SUV the Huletts' daughter had recently bought. Another time, the account posted a video.
去年秋天，石板岭脸书账号发布了一张SUV的照片，说他们正在找一辆一样的，用来做所谓的“车辆突击课程”，在那里车辆会被射击并炸毁。贴文里的SUV和休利特家女儿最近刚买的SUV的品牌、型号和颜色一模一样。另一次，该账号发布了一段视频。
Ladies and gentlemen, this is a 9 millimeter, full metal jacket, 115 grain bullet--
女士们先生们，这是一颗9毫米的全金属被甲子弹，115格令——
While Daniel narrates, the video shows a close up of a bronze bullet, then pans to the driver's side of a silver car.
当丹尼尔解说时，视频展示了一颗青铜子弹的特写，然后摇拍到一辆银色汽车的驾驶座一侧。
--that went through this door, through the car.
——它穿过了这扇门，穿过了车。
The door has been shot through multiple times, right where someone has written the words, "R. Hulett Trucking" on it. That's the name of one of the businesses the Huletts own.
门上被多次击穿，正好在有人写着“R. 休利特货运”（R. Hulett Trucking）的地方。那是休利特一家拥有的企业之一的名字。
So if you think that you can hide in your car and be safe behind the door from a bullet, you're wrong.
所以如果你认为躲在车里、躲在门后就能安全躲避子弹，你错了。
Mandy Hulett eventually got a no-stalking order against Daniel. And the Slate Ridge Facebook page is down now. But the neighbors say it was not just threats, but accusations, smears, and that Slate Ridge supporters would then like and comment on the posts.
曼迪·休利特最终申请了针对丹尼尔的禁止跟踪令。石板岭脸书页面现在已经关闭了。但邻居们说，不仅有威胁，还有指责、污蔑，而且石板岭的支持者会点赞并评论这些帖子。
It's just to threaten. It's idle threats. And it's just, once again, psychological warfare.
这只是为了威胁。这是空洞的威胁。这又是一次心理战。
It's idle unless one of his knuckleheads that's been going up there takes it a different way and takes it to another level.
这是空洞的，除非他手下那些上去的蠢货以不同方式看待它，并将其提升到另一个层面。
Yes.
是的。
They worried about Daniel's supporters. A few of the people training at Slate Ridge suggested online that they were affiliated with national militant groups, like the Three Percenters or a small local outfit with the grandiose name of the Vermont State Militia. Some of the neighbors did go to the police. But none of the things that Daniel and his supporters were doing seemed likely to bring criminal charges. It can be really hard to prosecute threats like these, unless they're very specific.
他们担心丹尼尔的支持者。一些在石板岭训练的人在网上暗示他们与全国性激进组织有关联，比如“三民主义者”（Three Percenters）或是一个有着“佛蒙特州民兵”这种宏大名称的小型本地组织。一些邻居确实报了警。但丹尼尔及其支持者所做的任何事情似乎都不太可能导致刑事指控。起诉这类威胁真的很困难，除非它们非常具体。
Daniel didn't just go after the neighbors. He made it sound like the town itself was conspiring against him. They were all in league with the Huletts, who he saw as his main opposition. Here he is at one town meeting, accusing the board of treating him unfairly.
丹尼尔不仅仅攻击邻居。他让事情听起来像是小镇本身在密谋反对他。他们都与休利特一家勾结，他认为那是他的主要对手。这是他在一次镇会议上指责委员会对他不公平。
I believe Mr. Bob Jones has a conflict of interest and has suppressed my rights and my existence in this community on three facts.
我相信鲍勃·琼斯（Bob Jones）先生有利益冲突，并以三个事实压制了我的权利和我在这个社区的存在。
Daniel points out that Jones, a board member, has worked for the trucking company owned by the Hulett family. Then he pivots to a different and very surprising attack.
丹尼尔指出，委员会成员琼斯曾为休利特家族拥有的货运公司工作过。然后他转入了一个不同且非常令人惊讶的攻击。
Furthermore, furthermore, this man has attended a Klan meeting by the group.
此外，此人参加了该团伙的3K党会议。
The meeting he's talking about is one of the ones the neighbors held to strategize about shutting down Daniel and Slate Ridge. But Daniel is calling it a Klan meeting, as in the Ku Klux Klan. Like, he's saying the neighbors are the KKK. This is part of a long-running and completely unsubstantiated claim of his that Pawlet is somehow run by white supremacists.
他谈到的会议是邻居们为了策划关闭丹尼尔和石板岭而召开的会议之一。但丹尼尔称之为3K党会议。就像是，他说邻居们是3K党。这是他长期以来完全没有根据的说法的一部分，他声称帕莱特在某种程度上被白人至上主义者控制。
You think it's funny. You think it's funny. And also had proceeded when the Hulett family took my gate down on my property. How is that legal for him to be here and to vote and not recuse and not have a misconduct? Mr. Cleveland, you laugh, too. The first six months of this opposition here, your son, Kenneth, was dating a Hulett. How can we not believe she didn't tell your son to tell you rhetoric to vote against me or diminish or sequester my rights in this community? You went to a Klan meeting, too.
你觉得这很有趣。你也觉得有趣。当休利特家族在我的土地上拆掉我的大门时，你也继续这样做。他在这里投票，不回避，不因不当行为受罚，这怎么合法？克利夫兰先生，你也笑了。这次反对行动的前六个月，你的儿子肯尼斯在和休利特家的人约会。我们怎么能不相信她没告诉你的儿子要你投反对票，或者是减少或剥夺我在这个社区的权利？你也参加了3K党会议。
I didn't go to any Klan meeting, let me tell you.
我没参加过任何3K党会议，我告诉你。
The meeting you went to, whatever the verbiage is, you were not supposed to be there. It's as simple as that.
你去参加的那个会议，不管措辞是什么，你都不应该在那儿。就这么简单。
I believe I went to the very first meeting they had. And that was to collect information.
我相信我参加了他们召开的第一次会议。那是为了收集信息。
OK, you're not supposed--
好的，你不应该——
Which I did.
我做了。
All right, you're not supposed to be doing that.
好的，你不应该那样做。
OK, and furthermore, I don't think-- anyhow.
好的，此外，我不认为——总之。
Listen.
听着。
I don't think you need to drag my son into it either.
我觉得你没必要把我的儿子也拖进来。
We're not dragging your son, but it's not ethical. You need to recuse yourself. You cannot allow these degenerates to start making things against me in this town, and then you vote on it.
我们没有拖你的儿子，但这不合道德。你需要回避。你不能允许这些堕落的人在这个镇上制造针对我的东西，然后你还投票支持它。
I think--
我觉得——
I think so.
我觉得。
I think-- I think this is-- before this gets out of control--
我觉得——我觉得这是——在失去控制之前——
It's not going to get out of control. I have complete control.
它不会失去控制。我完全在掌控之中。
It already is, as far as I know.
据我所知，已经失控了。
Daniel ramped up his attacks in the town. One post on the Slate Ridge Facebook page included a picture of Pawlet's town hall and said, quote, "No alarm, no security camera, single pane windows, no deadbolts, 30 to 40 minutes police response time, dead zone for all cell service, no safe room." People wrote in the comments that it was a soft target and noted the women on staff often worked late. Another post urged supporters to assemble at a town meeting with weapons and trauma kits, though none of them actually showed up.
丹尼尔升级了他在镇上的攻击。石板岭脸书页面上的一篇帖子包含了帕莱特镇大厅的照片，写道：“没有警报，没有监控摄像头，单层玻璃窗，没有防盗门锁，警察响应时间30到40分钟，所有手机服务盲区，没有安全屋。”人们在评论中写道，这是一个软目标，并指出工作人员中的女性经常加班。另一篇帖子敦促支持者带着武器和急救包聚集在镇会议上，尽管他们实际上一个都没出现。
There were other problems, too. In 2018, Daniel was banned from Pace University, where he'd been studying for a master's degree in Homeland Security. He'd allegedly sent a dean death threats over a text message. That led to a judge's order suspending his pistol permit in New York and requiring Daniel to surrender his firearms. When police searched his house, they found a handgun, which led prosecutors in New York to charge him with two felonies for criminal possession. Those are not resolved yet. According to a prosecutor, the majority of Daniel's pistols were transferred out of state, presumably to Vermont.
还有其他问题。2018年，丹尼尔被佩斯大学（Pace University）开除，他当时在那里攻读国土安全硕士学位。据说他曾通过短信向一位院长发出死亡威胁。这导致法官下令暂停他在纽约的持枪许可，并要求丹尼尔上交枪支。当警察搜查他的家时，发现了一把手枪，这导致纽约检察官以刑事持有罪对他提出了两项重罪指控。这些案件尚未结案。据检察官称，丹尼尔的大部分手枪都已被转移出州，大概到了佛蒙特州。
Up on the hill in Pawlet, the conflict was threatening to spiral. A sign posted on Daniel's property read, "Trespass here, die here." One night, two boys were bow hunting on the Huletts' property. Here's what happened next, according to allegations made to police. They shot a deer and tracked it to Daniel's land. As they approached, Daniel came down and threatened them. One boy called his dad. Things escalated. When Daniel asked them to identify themselves, they refused. And then Daniel said, "OK, you want to play that game? I'll shoot you." Nobody got hurt in the end. Daniel disputed that he threatened anyone. No charges were filed.
在帕莱特的山上，冲突威胁要升级。丹尼尔地产上贴着一块牌子，写着“擅入此地，死于此地”。一天晚上，两个男孩在休利特一家的土地上猎弓。根据向警方陈述的指控，接下来发生的事是这样的。他们射中了一头鹿，并追踪到了丹尼尔的土地。当他们靠近时，丹尼尔走下来威胁他们。一个男孩给他爸爸打了电话。事情升级了。当丹尼尔要求他们亮明身份时，他们拒绝了。然后丹尼尔说，“好的，你想玩这个游戏？那我就开枪打死你。”最后没人受伤。丹尼尔否认他威胁了任何人。没有任何指控被提出。
Coming up, reporter Mike Giglio looks into Daniel's background to try to figure out who Daniel really is and just how worried the neighbors should be. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，记者迈克·吉格里奥将深入研究丹尼尔的背景，试图弄清楚丹尼尔到底是谁，邻居们到底应该有多担心。这将在芝加哥公共广播电台的节目继续后播出。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "Don't You Be My Neighbor." We're devoting most of the hour today to the story of Pawlet, Vermont and what happened when one new person moved in. In this next part of the story, reporter Mike Giglio tries to answer the questions that lots of people in town had about their new neighbor. Here's Mike.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天节目的主题是“你不要做我的邻居”。我们今天大部分时间都致力于讲述佛蒙特州帕莱特的故事，以及一个人搬进来后发生了什么。在这个故事的下一部分，记者迈克·吉格里奥试图回答镇上许多人关于新邻居的问题。这是迈克。
I started writing about militia groups and civil violence last year. Ever since, I've been getting emails from people who are afraid of their neighbors. There was a Tennessee woman who suspected that hers were getting ready for, quote, "a bloodbath." A Michigan man who asked me if he should report a high school friend to authorities because of his Facebook posts. People wanted me to help them figure out how dangerous was their neighbor. That was how I heard about Slate Ridge and Daniel. Someone who lives near Pawlet sent me a message asking if I might want to investigate.
去年我开始撰写有关民兵组织和内战的文章。从那时起，我就不断收到那些害怕邻居的人发来的电子邮件。有一位田纳西州的妇女怀疑她的邻居正准备迎接一场“血洗”。一名密歇根州的男子问我，是否因为他朋友的脸书贴文而应该向当局举报他。人们希望我帮他们弄清楚邻居到底有多危险。这就是我听说石板岭和丹尼尔的经过。一个住在帕莱特附近的人给我发了条消息，问我是否愿意去调查。
You can drive yourself crazy these days, wondering if everyone threatening violence is serious or only trolling. When I was interviewing people in militia groups last year, for example, I often had the feeling that it was all just posturing. That all their talk about civil violence was just a mask for other anxieties. Then some people affiliated with these groups-- according to the FBI, at least-- took part in the attack on the US Capitol. People can seem like they're not really serious until they are.
这些天，你真的会把自己搞疯，想知道每个威胁暴力的人是认真的还是仅仅在钓鱼。去年我采访民兵组织成员时，例如，我经常有一种感觉，这只是装腔作势。他们谈论内战的话题只不过是掩盖其他焦虑的伪装。然后一些与这些组织有关联的人——至少根据联邦调查局的说法——参与了对美国国会大厦的袭击。人们看起来并不认真，直到他们真的付诸行动。
Daniel Banyai's neighbors don't know how scared they should be of him, like how Mandy Hulett said in one moment that he's probably just full of hot air, but also has that no-stalking order against him. And she wrote a Facebook post saying she wanted people to know about Daniel's threats, in case anything ever happened to her.
丹尼尔·巴尼亚的邻居们不知道该有多害怕他，就像曼迪·休利特有时说他可能只是空谈，但也有那个禁止跟踪令。她写了一篇脸书文章，说她想让人们知道丹尼尔的威胁，以防她发生什么事。
And for all the research into Daniel, in the end, neighbors really don't know that much about his background. I spoke on the phone with him a couple of times, but he wouldn't let me record him. And he was evasive about almost every question I asked. I spoke to the head of Public Safety in Vermont, the major from the state police who was their point person for Daniel, and someone from the Vermont Intelligence Center, an agency that coordinates between local and federal law enforcement. I even sent his YouTube video with Adam, the Boogaloo guy, to a recently retired agent from the FBI.
尽管对丹尼尔进行了种种研究，到最后，邻居们对他背景了解的确实不多。我曾与他在电话里交谈过几次，但他不允许我录音。他对几乎所有我问的问题都避而不答。我采访了佛蒙特州的公共安全负责人，那位与丹尼尔对接的州警少校，以及来自佛蒙特情报中心的一位人士，这是一家协调地方和联邦执法机构的机构。我甚至把他和布加洛男孩亚当的YouTube视频发给了一位刚退休的FBI探员。
But in the end, the person who knew the most about Daniel was his ex-wife, Gina Mahar-Daniels. They met in 1992, when she was 16 and he was 19.
但最后，对丹尼尔了解最多的人是他的前妻吉娜·马哈尔-丹尼尔斯（Gina Mahar-Daniels）。他们在1992年相识，当时她16岁，他19岁。
At our local mall, there's a pizzeria called Roman Delight. And Dan was the pizza man there.
在我们当地的商场，有一家叫“罗马愉悦”（Roman Delight）的比萨店。丹就是那里的比萨师傅。
You said pizza man. You mean-- what was his job?
你说比萨师傅。你是说——他的工作是什么？
Literally the pizza man. He was the guy that was making the pies.
字面意义上的比萨师傅。他就是那个制作馅饼的人。
Gina told me she and Daniel both grew up in upstate New York. He had half siblings he didn't really talk about. He was close with his dad, who died before they met. Daniel eventually quit his job at the pizza shop and enrolled at the Culinary Institute of America. But he dropped out right before he finished. He had a job running restaurants for a bit. Gina got pregnant, and soon after, Daniel decided to join the Army.
吉娜告诉我，她和丹尼尔都是在纽约州北部长大的。他有几个不常谈论的同父异母兄弟姐妹。他和父亲很亲近，但他父亲在他们认识前就去世了。丹尼尔最终从比萨店辞职，进入了美国烹饪学院（CIA）。但他在毕业前就辍学了。他做过一段时间的餐馆经营工作。吉娜怀孕了，不久后，丹尼尔决定参军。
And so I thought that was a great idea. Good. That's good. We're kind of setting ourselves up. We're a young family. Good idea. So he gets sworn in. He leaves for basic training and calls me a few days in to let me know that they found cysts on his neck and that he was going to be coming home with a medical discharge.
我觉得这是个好主意。太好了。我们算是安定下来了。我们是一个年轻的家庭。好主意。所以他宣誓入伍了。他离开去参加基本训练，几天后给我打电话，告诉我他们发现他脖子上有囊肿，他将被医疗退役回家。
So pretty much two weeks to the day that I dropped him off at the airport, I was picking him up again because he had been discharged from the Army for supposedly these cysts that he never did anything about. Supposedly, a medical discharge. I honestly don't know if that was the truth or if that was not the truth. But he was not in the Army.
所以基本上在我把他送到机场的那天起，过了两周，我就又去接他了，因为他被军队退役了，据说是为了那些他从未处理过的囊肿。所谓的医疗退役。我老实说不知道那是真相还是谎言。但他不在军队了。
The National Personnel Records Center confirmed that Daniel's time in the army lasted all of two weeks.
国家人事档案中心证实，丹尼尔在军队的时间总共只有两周。
What was it that made him want to join the military?
是什么促使他想参加军队？
Honestly it was security, just strictly financial security. Not because he had any sort of calling to do so or sense of duty or-- nothing like that. Literally just like, oh, they'll provide us with a house to live in, money, security, health insurance, that sort of thing.
老实说就是安全感，仅仅是财务上的安全感。并不是因为他有什么使命感或责任感之类的——什么都没有。字面上就是，“噢，他们会提供房子住、钱、安全感、医疗保险，诸如此类的东西。”
Was he patriotic at all? Do you remember?
他爱国吗？你记得吗？
Not particularly, no.
并不特别，没有。
In talking with people close to Daniel, I got the sense that he didn't believe in anything very strongly. He's not an ideologue. He's not really a militia type. Those guys will go on for hours about the Constitution. But he does like to present himself as someone with a mysterious past, maybe even a dangerous one. From the time he met Gina at the pizza shop, she told me, he would suggest that he was connected with the mafia, like when John Gotti died in 2002. Daniel said he was distraught, that he had to go to the funeral. She says he didn't go. And then there's their son.
在与接近丹尼尔的人交谈时，我觉得他并没有强烈信仰什么。他不是一个思想家，也不是真正的民兵类型。那些家伙会花几个小时讨论宪法。但他确实喜欢把自己展示成一个有神秘背景，甚至危险过去的人。吉娜告诉我，从她在比萨店认识他时起，他就会暗示自己与黑手党有联系，就像2002年约翰·高蒂（John Gotti）去世时那样。丹尼尔说他很悲痛，他必须去参加葬礼。她说他没去。还有他们的儿子。
I'm Gumbrotti Luciano Banyai. I know you can't see me, but I'm doing the Italian hand. You put all your fingers together, pointing at the sky. I find that that helps people with my name, but Gumbrotti Luciano Banyai.
我是Gumbrotti Luciano Banyai。我知道你看不到我，但我正在做意大利手势。你把所有手指合在一起，指着天空。我发现这对人们记住我的名字有帮助，我是Gumbrotti Luciano Banyai。
If you're trying to remember what movie the name Gumbrotti's from, where you've heard it before, you haven't. There's only one Gumbrotti.
如果你想记起Gumbrotti这个名字出自哪部电影，你曾在哪里听说过，你没听过。只有一个Gumbrotti。
Has it always been a point of discussion with people?
它一直是一个人们讨论的话题吗？
Oh, yeah. Well, I just tell them my dad made it up. Actually, I tell them-- I say, "Hi, my name is Gumbrotti Banyai." And they go, "Oh, Gumbrotti?" I said, "Yeah, it's my real name. It's a fake name, but it's my name." Like, it's not a real name. I'm the only one, but it's my name, you know?
噢，是的。嗯，我只是告诉他们是我爸爸编出来的。事实上，我告诉他们——我说，“嗨，我叫Gumbrotti Banyai。”他们说，“噢，Gumbrotti？”我说，“是的，这是我的真名。这是个假名字，但它是我的名字。”就像，它不是一个真名字。我是唯一的，但它是我的名字，你知道吗？
When I was pregnant, we were talking about names. And he was like, "Ah, I want to name him something strong. And I want to name him Gumbrotti." And I'm like, "Oh, God, no, absolutely not. Seriously, that's horrendous. We're not going to name him that." He's like, "No, no, no, listen, listen. That was somebody from my past. And it was somebody I can't really talk about it, but somebody who was really important to me. He was kind of like a father figure."
我怀孕时，我们在讨论名字。他说：“啊，我想给他起个响亮的名字。我想叫他Gumbrotti。”我说，“噢，上帝，不，绝对不行。说真的，这太可怕了。我们不会叫他那个。”他说，“不，不，不，听着，听着。那是从我过去认识的一个人。那是对我来说非常重要、但我真的不能谈论的人。他有点像父亲的形象。”
And so I acquiesced at that point. I'm like, "All right, fine. This is a namesake. This is something that's really important to you. Fine." And later on, in years, it came up in conversation. I think someone was asking us together. And then he was like, "Oh, no, no, I made that up." I was like, "Are you serious? You made that up? You told me that was--" "Oh, no, no, no, no." No, and yeah. He's like, "It's a cool name. I just needed you to be on board." You mother [BLEEP]. Yeah, I was not happy.
所以当时我就妥协了。我想，“好吧，好吧。这是同名纪念，这是对他来说非常重要的事情。好吧。”几年后，它在谈话中出现了。我想有人问我们两个。然后他说，“噢，不，不，我不记得了，是我编的。”我说，“你是认真的？是你编的？你告诉我那是——”“噢，不，不，不，不。”不，是的。他说：“这名字很酷。我只是需要你同意。”你这个混蛋。是的，我不高兴。
Was the mafia thing kind of-- was it important to his presentation?
黑手党的事对他来说重要吗？
It was, honestly. I mean-- he needs to be the toughest guy in the room.
真的很重要。我是说——他需要成为房间里最强硬的家伙。
After he was discharged from the Army, Daniel eventually started a landscaping business. He called it Tutiano Burgante Excavation-- also fake words. He had a knack for landscaping. I actually found an old article about him winning an award for stonewall preservation. But his record includes at least a dozen court cases-- people he owed money to who he never paid, a car repossession, a mortgage default. In 2006, he pled guilty to making a fake workman's comp claim. The landscaping business filed for bankruptcy in 2011.
从军队退役后，丹尼尔最终开始了一项景观美化业务。他称之为“Tutiano Burgante挖掘”（这也是假词）。他擅长景观美化。我确实找到了一篇关于他赢得石墙保护奖的旧文章。但他的记录中至少有十几起法庭案件——他欠钱不还的人、汽车被收回、抵押贷款违约。2006年，他因提出虚假工伤补偿申请而认罪。他的景观美化业务在2011年申请破产。
Gina said Daniel was abusive. She said he hit her multiple times. She said she didn't file police reports about it, but told her therapist and her best friend, who both confirmed this. Once they were arguing in the car, and Daniel reached over and bashed her head against the window. Gumbrotti was there. He says he remembers it. And then there were periods when things would be OK. It could be hard for even his own family to know what to make of him. Daniel and Gumbrotti didn't speak for several years. They reconnected when Gumbrotti was 18. Daniel had an entirely new persona.
吉娜说丹尼尔有虐待倾向。她说他多次殴打她。她说她没报案，但告诉了治疗师和最好的朋友，他们都证实了这一点。有一次他们在车里争吵，丹尼尔伸手把她的头撞向窗户。Gumbrotti当时在场，他说他记得这件事。然后有一些时候情况还行。甚至连他自己的家人也很难知道该如何看待他。丹尼尔和Gumbrotti有好几年没说话。他们在Gumbrotti 18岁时重新建立了联系。丹尼尔有了全新的形象。
He was just different. He had a different way of carrying himself. He seemed more military lifestyle. Then he was like, "Oh, yeah, I'm executive protection, security." And I asked him to explain it. And I was like, "So you're a security guard or a contractor?" And he was like-- the exact words-- because it's such a stupid statement, I remember it. He says, "Oh, I escorted essential and nonessential personnel through the theater of battle." And I was like, "Oh, OK, cool." And then I remember him saying it to other people.
他就是变了。他的举止变了。他看起来更像是军事生活方式。然后他说，“噢，是的，我是行政保护，安保。”我让他解释一下。我当时说，“所以你是保安还是承包商？”他说——原话——因为那是一句太蠢的话，我记得很清楚。他说，“噢，我护送必要和非必要人员穿过战场。”我就说，“噢，好的，酷。”然后我记得他向其他人也说过。
As for Daniel's claim that he's a private military contractor, he did start a security company called Garm Dynamics in 2014 with a guy named Ian Spurgeon, a former officer in the Swedish military. The two of them met in an executive protection training course in Denmark. Ian said, at the training, Daniel really impressed him. He said it looked like he had real experience.
至于丹尼尔声称他是私人军事承包商，他确实在2014年与一个名叫伊恩·斯普金（Ian Spurgeon）的人成立了一家名为Garm Dynamics的安保公司，后者是瑞典军队的前军官。两人在丹麦的一次行政保护培训课程中相识。伊恩说，在培训中，丹尼尔确实给他留下了深刻印象。他说看起来他确实有实际经验。
Did he say he had-- any details of the work? Had it been overseas? Had it been in high stress environments? Anything like that?
他说过他有吗——工作的细节？是海外吗？在高压力环境下吗？类似那样？
Yeah, he said he had overseas contracts and with the US government and also with the private sector. And again, from my background, I'm prone not to ask questions because, really, if it's not my need to know, then I really don't ask any questions.
是的，他说他有海外合同，有美国政府的，也有私营部门的。同样，从我的背景来看，我往往不会问问题，因为真的，如果我不需要知道，那我就真的不会问任何问题。
The idea was that Garm Dynamics would do security contracting and train people in military tactics. The Garm website had seals from the Department of Homeland Security and other government agencies on it. But Ian told me that they never actually worked for any of them. He said Daniel had assured him it was OK to use the logos. The website also said the company was, quote, "established and facilitated by elite military and government personnel."
想法是Garm Dynamics会做安全承包，并教授人们军事战术。Garm网站上有国土安全部和其他政府机构的印章。但伊恩告诉我，他们实际上从未为其中任何一家工作过。他说丹尼尔向他保证使用这些标志没问题。网站还说该公司是“由精英军事和政府人员建立和推动的”。
Was there anyone else that was elite military government personnel besides you?
除了你之外，还有其他精英军事政府人员吗？
No, it was only the two of us. But I don't know how we add that, but again-- enhancing the marketability of the company.
没有，只有我们两个。我不知道我们怎么加上去的，但还是——增强公司的市场竞争力。
Yeah, right. But you said you have multifaceted teams of industry experts, forensic analysts, intelligence experts, on-the-ground sources, provide intelligence and risk assessment. Is that also just marketing?
是的，对吧。但你说你们拥有多元化的行业专家团队、法医分析师、情报专家、现场消息来源，提供情报和风险评估。那也只是营销吗？
Uh, yeah.
呃，是的。
OK. And there's a picture of-- this is one thing-- there's a picture of these dudes in a helicopter. And their faces are blurred out.
好的。而且有一张照片——这是一件事——有一张这些家伙在直升机里的照片。他们的脸被模糊处理了。
Yeah, that's a stock photo, I think it is.
是的，我想那是库存照片。
Ian said Garm never got any contracts, never did any trainings, at least when he was there. Eventually, Daniel seemed to be getting sucked more and more into his problems up in Vermont, and the company died.
伊恩说Garm从未获得任何合同，从未做过任何培训，至少在他那里的时候。最终，丹尼尔似乎越来越深地卷入他在佛蒙特州的问题中，公司倒闭了。
Daniel also registered a second company that is still active. But I could find only one person on LinkedIn who said he'd worked there, and when I messaged him about this, he deleted it from his profile. It's hard to say for sure if Daniel ever did work as a private military contractor, or if he did, whether it really entailed dodging bullets in Iraq, as he once claimed to me. You can't check that kind of thing through public records requests. And people who do private contractor work also usually have to sign nondisclosure agreements.
丹尼尔还注册了第二家公司，目前仍然活跃。但我只能在LinkedIn上找到一个人说他在那里工作过，当我发消息询问时，他从个人资料中删除了。很难肯定丹尼尔是否真的担任过私人军事承包商，或者如果担任过，是否真的像他曾经对我声称的那样在伊拉克躲避子弹。你无法通过公共记录请求核实那种事情。而且从事私人承包工作的人通常也必须签署保密协议。
The other work Daniel says he's done is executive protection, which is the business of guarding the rich and famous. We were able to confirm one aspect of this. Daniel worked for a time on a detail protecting Ben Shapiro, a conservative commentator, though he was ultimately fired from that job.
丹尼尔说他做的另一项工作是行政保护，即守护富人和名人的生意。我们证实了其中的一个方面。丹尼尔曾有一段时间负责保护保守派评论员本·夏皮罗（Ben Shapiro），尽管他最终被那份工作解雇了。
I spoke with a few people who consider themselves part of the Slate Ridge family. They see a totally different version of Daniel than the neighbors do. Samantha Shumway is one of the co-founders of the Vermont State Militia. She says they're survivalists. They're a pretty small group, about 10 members. They train once a month. She's 32, has four kids, who call Daniel "Uncle Daniel."
我与几个认为自己是石板岭大家庭一部分的人谈过。他们看到的丹尼尔版本与邻居看到的完全不同。萨曼莎·舒姆威（Samantha Shumway）是“佛蒙特州民兵”的联合创始人之一。她说他们是生存主义者。他们是一个很小的团体，大约10名成员。他们每月训练一次。她32岁，有四个孩子，他们叫丹尼尔“丹尼尔叔叔”。
She told me he's not dangerous at all. He's just someone who wants to share his knowledge about guns. He taught them all firearm safety. She and the other militia members drive about two hours to get to Slate Ridge, even though there are much closer ranges, because the facility is so nice and because Daniel is so warm and welcoming.
她告诉我说他一点也不危险。他只是一个想分享他关于枪支知识的人。他教了他们所有人枪支安全。她和其他民兵成员开车约两个小时前往石板岭，尽管有更近的靶场，因为设施非常好，而且丹尼尔非常热情好客。
She doesn't believe the neighbors are really as scared as they say. She thinks they're exaggerating their fears because they don't want a noisy shooting range in their neighborhood, and they're afraid of change. They haven't even met us, she told me.
她不相信邻居们真的像他们说的那么害怕。她认为他们夸大了恐惧，因为他们不希望在邻居中有一个嘈杂的射击场，而且他们害怕改变。她告诉我，他们甚至还没见过我们。
She did think the Facebook threats were over the line. After the Hulett Trucking video, she and some others in the Slate Ridge family told Daniel he needed to stop. It was all part of what she called a battle between neighbors, which she didn't see how it could end at this point. But the thing she was more worried about was the government taking Daniel's land. It's a piece of him, she told me.
她确实认为脸书上的威胁越界了。在休利特货运的视频后，她和石板岭大家庭中的一些其他人告诉丹尼尔他需要停止。这一切都是她所谓的“邻里之战”的一部分，她看不到这件事在这一点上如何结束。但她更担心的是政府没收丹尼尔的土地。她告诉我，那是他的一部分。
In any community, there are basic rules and laws we agree to live by. It's how we're able to coexist. But in Pawlet, Daniel was clearly not participating in all that. And the state agencies that are meant to enforce those rules don't seem to be able to do anything about it. It's like he's managed to outmaneuver them, simply by creating chaos. For instance, with the state's Natural Resources Board, Daniel might be in violation of a Vermont land use law, but they need to prove that he's running a business. And he says he's not, that everything at Slate Ridge is free. And so far, the Natural Resources Board hasn't been able to prove otherwise.
在任何社区，都有我们同意遵守的基本规则和法律。这就是我们能够共存的方式。但在帕莱特，丹尼尔显然没有参与这一切。而旨在执行这些规则的州政府机构似乎对此无能为力。就像他仅仅通过制造混乱就成功地击败了他们。例如，对于州的自然资源委员会，丹尼尔可能违反了佛蒙特州的土地使用法，但他们需要证明他在经营生意。而他说他没有，石板岭的一切都是免费的。到目前为止，自然资源委员会还无法证明这一点。
And take those cases in New York. One of them is a restraining order against him, which required him to surrender his firearms. I asked law enforcement authorities in Vermont about this. Could they enforce New York's order? Go and seize his guns? They said, yes, they could. But here's the irony. Even though the neighbors have been hearing all that shooting for so long, even though Daniel talks about all the weapons he has, there's no hard proof that he currently has any in his possession. If you look at his Facebook posts, photos, videos, he never appears with a gun.
看看纽约的那些案件。其中一个是针对他的限制令，要求他上交枪支。我问过佛蒙特州的执法机构。他们能执行纽约的命令吗？去没收他的枪支？他们说，可以，他们能。但讽刺的是。尽管邻居们听了那么久的枪声，尽管丹尼尔谈论他拥有的所有武器，但没有确凿证据表明他目前拥有任何枪支。如果你看他的脸书文章、照片、视频，他从未带着枪出现。
For a while now, some of the neighbors have had this feeling that's new to them, that the system is failing them, that the protection that they thought it provided isn't actually there. I think this can create a special kind of anxiety. And it's led them to take things into their own hands.
有一段时间了，一些邻居有一种对他们来说是新的感觉，即系统正在辜负他们，他们认为它提供的保护实际上并不存在。我认为这可以制造一种特殊的焦虑。它导致他们采取自己的行动。
This is my Kevlar vest.
这是我的凯夫拉背心。
So this is underneath your bedroom window.
所以这是在你卧室窗户下面的。
Mm-hmm.
嗯嗯。
Yeah.
是的。
Beth showed me around her house. She and Ray have weapons hidden everywhere, just in case.
贝丝带我参观了她的家。她和雷到处都藏着武器，以防万一。
This is my favorite weapon.
这是我最喜欢的武器。
You got a shotgun leaned against the window sill.
你有一把猎枪靠在窗台上。
And this is my 243.
这是我的243。
Can you describe it to me?
你能描述一下它吗？
My beautiful camouflage 243 I bought on a whim because it was pretty. It's got a high-powered scope. It's camouflaged pretty pink, because I'm a girl. And I've got 1, 2, 3, 4 5 clips of 243 bullets that are already locked and loaded. Two years ago, I would have never-- it only takes one bullet to kill a deer. Why do you think I have all these? To protect my family. And these are my family. My neighbors are my family. So Banyai has family, we have family, too.
我美丽的迷彩243，我是随手买的，因为它很漂亮。它有一个高倍率瞄准镜。它是粉红色的迷彩，因为我是个女孩。我有1、2、3、4、5夹243子弹，已经锁定并装填好了。两年前，我绝不会——杀死一只鹿只需要一颗子弹。你为什么认为我有这么多？为了保护我的家人。他们是我的家人。我的邻居是我的家人。所以巴尼亚有家人，我们也有家人。
Are there other ammo and gun spots in the house tactically placed?
家里还有其他弹药和枪支放置点吗？
You can see a couple over there. I spy with my little eye.
你可以看到那边有几个。我用我的小眼睛监视着。
Oh, wow, it's just behind the bedroom door.
噢，哇，它就在卧室门后面。
Oh, yeah. Oh, you saw the 30-30 in the bathroom.
噢，是的。噢，你看到了浴室里的30-30。
I did not. I guess I wasn't being observant.
我没看到。我想我没那么敏锐。
I'm starting to lose count of how many guns she's showed me.
我开始数不清她展示给我看多少枪了。
It's great. So but you have a gun, it seems-- I think you forgot some of them. But there's one just like-- they're like Easter eggs all over the house.
太棒了。所以你有一把枪，看起来——我想你忘记了一些。但有一把就像——它们像复活节彩蛋一样遍布房子。
Yes, and that happens to be my favorite holiday, so that's OK.
是的，那恰好是我最喜欢的节日，所以没关系。
Why in the bathroom?
为什么在浴室里？
Well, what if? I wouldn't want to get caught off guard, you know? I'm just saying. And it's near the back door. So if you had to run in and grab one, you know? Yeah.
嗯，万一呢？我不想被措手不及，你知道吗？我只是这么说。而且它靠近后门。所以如果必须跑进去拿一把，你知道吗？是的。
The Tilanders' comfortable country home has a warped Norman Rockwell feel now. They've stockpiled weapons around their house, too. There's a loaded handgun in the cookie cabinet. The first thing Paul does every morning is search for a new post from Slate Ridge. When the Tilanders moved to Pawlet a decade ago, they planned a retirement of gardening and enjoying the views. Instead, Michelle looks out her kitchen window and imagines Daniel or his supporters creeping through the woods, lying down in hedgerow and aiming their guns into the house.
蒂兰德家舒适的乡村住宅现在有一种扭曲的诺曼·洛克威尔式的感觉。他们也在房子周围囤积了武器。饼干柜里有一把装弹的手枪。保罗每天早上做的第一件事就是搜索石板岭的新帖子。当蒂兰德一家十年前搬到帕莱特时，他们计划退休生活，园艺，欣赏美景。相反，米歇尔看向她的厨房窗户，想象着丹尼尔或他的支持者在树林里爬行，躺在绿篱里，把枪指向房子。
His Facebook has posted pictures of his cronies with their ARs and their camo and all that, walking through the woods.
他的脸书发了他的亲信带着AR、迷彩服和所有装备在树林里走的照片。
But do you imagine someone coming down the road here, where it's so close?
但你想象有人会走这条路过来吗，这里离得这么近？
Nah.
不。
No, I think they would come through the field.
不，我想他们会穿过田野。
You're pointing out the back window here?
你指着这边的后窗？
The back window.
后窗。
Well--
嗯——
I think they come through the fields to avoid being seen. There's a fair amount of traffic on this road.
我想他们会穿过田野以避免被看见。这条路上有相当多的交通。
You can come up that back-- by the creek there, where the land drops away. Walk right up and just lay down in that hedgerow. And here we are. This is where we spend most of our time. Yeah, that's what we live with now.
你可以从后面上来——在那边的溪流旁，土地下降的地方。走上来然后躺在那片绿篱里。我们就这样。这就是我们现在的生活。
I don't know how many times I've come to this sink, looked out this window, pulled the blinds and said, if someone's going to shoot me, they're going to shoot me. We're older now. So we kind of accept that our days are numbered. Not afraid of that. I've had a great life. But I've still got grandkids I want to see grow up married. So we try to protect ourselves as best we can.
我不知道多少次来到这个水槽前，看向窗外，拉下百叶窗说，如果有人要枪击我，他们就会枪击我。我们老了。所以我们接受我们的日子不多了。不害怕这个。我度过了伟大的一生。但我还有想看到结婚长大的孙子。所以我们尽力保护自己。
Paul has an AR-15. Most homeowners use bullets with hollow points, which stop when they hit a target so that they won't keep on traveling and hit a bystander or a neighbor. But Paul's gun is loaded with solid points.
保罗有一把AR-15。大多数房主使用空尖弹，击中目标时会停下，这样就不会继续穿行伤害到路人或邻居。但保罗的枪里装的是实心弹。
Why did you go for the solid rather than the hollow?
你为什么选择实心而不是空尖？
Well, normally, I would prefer a hollow point if I had to shoot a varmint outside. But these people up the road here, they all wear armor-plated vests with metal plates. And the penetrating power of a hollow point is much less than a solid point. So-- I don't like the idea of having to be prepared for this. But I think we have to.
嗯，通常如果我必须射击外面的害兽，我更喜欢空尖弹。但路上这些人，他们都穿带金属板的防弹背心。空尖弹的穿透力远小于实心弹。所以——我不喜欢必须为这种事做准备的想法。但我觉得我们必须这样。
Something did happen for the neighbors recently. It actually looks like Slate Ridge might get shut down. And you know what did it? It wasn't the governor or the attorney general or the ATF or the state's Natural Resources Board or the state police. It was the tiny town of Pawlet. Their zoning case finally worked its way through the courts. And after years of delays, in March, a state superior court upheld the town zoning laws and ruled against Daniel.
最近邻居们确实发生了一些事。实际上看起来石板岭可能会被关闭。你知道是什么促成了吗？不是州长、司法部长、ATF、州的自然资源委员会或州警。是帕莱特这个小镇。他们的分区案件最终在法院走了一遍。经过多年的拖延，在三月，州高级法院维护了镇分区法，做出了对丹尼尔不利的裁决。
The neighbors say the shooting has stopped for the most part, but they still hear construction noise from time to time. They think he's building another two ranges. The judge ordered Daniel to dismantle the buildings at Slate Ridge and pay $100 for each day he hasn't fixed his zoning violations, which came to $46,600. In his ruling, he detailed how Daniel has refused to comply with the town since 2017. He wrote, quote, "Mr. Banyai's record of compliance has been horrendous."
邻居们说枪声大部分时间已经停止，但他们不时还会听到施工噪音。他们认为他在建另外两个靶场。法官命令丹尼尔拆除石板岭的建筑，并为他没有修复分区违规行为的每一天支付100美元，总计46,600美元。在裁决中，他详细说明了丹尼尔自2017年以来如何拒绝遵守小镇规定。他写道：“巴尼亚先生的合规记录是可怕的。”
Daniel has appealed the ruling, of course. This could still drag on for a bit. And there's one thing that won't change. Even if the range gets shut down, even if the buildings get knocked down, Daniel will still own that land. And Paul, Michelle, and everyone else up on the hill?
丹尼尔当然对裁决提出了上诉。这可能还会拖延一段时间。有一件事不会改变。即使靶场被关闭，即使建筑被拆除，丹尼尔仍将拥有那块土地。那保罗、米歇尔以及山上的其他人呢？
We're not moving, and we're not quitting.
我们不会搬走，我们也不会放弃。
Yeah, I agree with that.
是的，我同意这一点。
So for now, at least, they're all still going to be neighbors.
所以至少现在，他们都还会是邻居。
Mike Giglio. We'd also like to give a shout out to the local press in Vermont, which has done a great job covering all this-- VTDigger, Vermont Public Radio, and the Manchester Journal.
迈克·吉格里奥。我们也想给佛蒙特州的当地媒体点赞，他们在报道所有这些方面做得很好——VTDigger、佛蒙特公共广播电台和曼彻斯特期刊。
[MUSIC - "NEIGHBORS" BY LUCIUS]
[音乐 - 卢修斯的《邻居》]
[CREDITS]
[致谢]
And our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 700 episodes for absolutely free. Also, there are videos. There are lists of favorite shows for your summer road trip listening. Tons of other stuff there, too. Again, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's confounder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He told me he could sum up any movie in nine words or fewer. I was like, OK, Big Lebowski, go.
还有我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费流媒体播放我们超过700集的存档节目。此外，还有视频。有为你夏季公路旅行收听推荐的最爱节目列表。上面还有很多其他东西。再次说明，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》通过公共广播交流中心PRX传送到公共广播电台。感谢一如既往我们项目的联合创始人Torey Malatia先生。他告诉我他能用九个或更少的字总结任何电影。我说，OK，《大勒博斯基》，开始。
A rich guy, a mansion, a car being towed.
一个富人，一栋豪宅，一辆被拖走的车。
All right, stolen and crashed, then towed, but yeah, pretty good. I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
好吧，被偷和撞坏，然后被拖走，但是的，很不错。我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC - "NEIGHBORS" BY LUCIUS]
[音乐 - 卢修斯的《邻居》]